[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 13 avril
c'était l'une des mesures emblématiques
de la rentrée scolaire 2010 est les cpa
12 sont désormais installés et ce depuis
six mois quel bilan en tirez quels sont
les avantages pour les écoliers et les
professeurs nous sommes allés dans l'une
des classes qui profitent du dispositif
à trappes
reportage à suivre dès le début de cette
émission se sont beaucoup plus grands
les étudiants manifestent en ce moment
leur opposition à la réforme de
l'université et une sélection cacher
selon eux les manifestants qui bloquent
certaines universités peuvent compter
sur le soutien parfois d'enseignants
c'est le cas de notre invité matthieu
hély enseignants chercheurs à lui vécu
dans le reste de l'actualité nous
reviendrons sur le rapprochement amorcé
entre les villes de coignières et
maurepas où l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui songe à évoluer
en communauté urbaine vacances de
printemps oblige la circulation risque
d'être compliqué sur certains axes
franciliens ce week-end bison futé
prévoit des difficultés dans le sens des
départs samedi la journée est classée
orange en région parisienne avec
notamment des ralentissements au péage
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines entre 8h et
16h et globalement il est conseillé de
prendre la route tôt le matin pour
quitter l'île de france ou dans la
soirée les transports en commun sont eux
aussi impacté par la grève qui repart
vendredi et samedi nouvelle journée de
grève des cheminots pour connaître
l'état de circulation de vos trains
rendez vous sur transilien un point com
et ce début des vacances va permettre
évidemment aux écoliers de se reposer
pour une quinzaine de jours
c'est aussi l'occasion de faire un bilan
pour les cp des doublés cette
mesure-phare du ministre de l'éducation
mise en place lors de la rentrée en
septembre dernier vise à maximiser l la
réussite scolaire des écoliers dans les
quartiers les plus fragiles à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 4 et école
élémentaire de trappes ont ces classes
préparatoires ses cours préparatoire
avec douze élèves maximum
reportage
j'ai reçu du jour et pour faire du sport
[Musique]
ce matin là cet atelier lecture pour les
cp de l'école henri wallon de trappes
[Musique]
pour faire la lecture la maîtresse
madame le moigne a la chance de pouvoir
suivre chacun des écoliers dans cette
classe bénéficiaires du dispositif cpd
doublé ils ne sont que onze élèves
la maîtresse peut ainsi répondre aux
besoins des enfants et s'adapter au
rythme de chacun si ce jour là il ya un
élève qui préférait qu'il y avait bien
là qui le son qu'on avait travaillé
aujourd'hui il a voulu directement pour
le texte en entier il a pu le faire un
élève qui est pas prêt à le faire
aujourd'hui elle va le faire dans deux
jours et il réussira il sera en réussite
et
et c'est ce qu'on cherche je pense avec
le cp 100% réussite douze élèves par
classe maximum dans les zones dites
serait plus c'est aussi une nouvelle
relation qu'il faut bâtir entre enfants
et enseignants c'est aussi enfin
l'occasion pour tous de s'exprimer de
manière beaucoup plus importante
qu'auparavant et que chaque enfant un
temps parole dans la classe qui est
beaucoup plus long que ce qu'il a vu ce
qu'il aurait eue en cp classique et ça
les fait progresser les élèves qui était
plus fragile plus timides ou plaidant
difficulté progresse d'autant plus grâce
à son lot de fonctions à trappes depuis
la rentrée 2010 7,9 nouvelles classes
ont dû être créé pour accueillir maximum
douze élèves par enseignant
le dispositif sera élargie à la rentrée
prochaine à cinq nouvelles écoles de la
commune
les ce1 devrait aussi commencer à en
profiter un véritable casse tête
logistique pour la mairie au lieu
d'avoir comme à cette rentrée précédente
une classe individuelle de 12 élèves
on va être obligé de mettre deux
enseignants par classe en septembre
prochain deux écoles élémentaires de
plaisir profiteront aussi du cpd doublé
l'ensemble du dispositif ne sera qu
entièrement déployé dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire qu'à la rentrée
2010 9 et certains de ces écoliers
seront peut-être d'ici une douzaine
d'années sur les bancs de l'université
ils devront sûrement alors remplir leurs
voeux sur la nouvelle plateforme
parcours sur cette plateforme
inscrite dans le cadre d'une réforme de
l'entrée à l'université et de
l'orientation et qui continue de faire
débat une dizaine d'universités serait
encore bloquées totalement ou
partiellement par un mouvement de lutte
contre cette réforme le ton est monté
cette semaine à nanterre ou à la
sorbonne avec l'intervention des forces
de l'ordre parmi les opposants il ya les
étudiants mais aussi certains
enseignants matthieu hély bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes enseignant chercheur à
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines membres de
l'association des sociologues
enseignants du supérieur et co
signataires d'une tribune qui est paru
cette semaine sur france info avec plus
de 400 de vos collègues une tribune dans
laquelle il est inscrit notamment je
cite la nouvelle loi instaure une
sélection absurde c'est un argument que
réfute aujourd'hui en bloc le
gouvernement alors qui dit vrai qui dit
faux
pourquoi vous vous parlez de sélection
alors il ya plusieurs choses dont il ya
beaucoup de choses à la tribune a gelé
les u13 oui pourquoi on parle de
sélection parce que tout simplement le
principe d'accès à l'université à partir
du moment où vous êtes bacheliers est
inscrit dans le code de l'éducation
depuis 50 ans depuis la loi ford de 1968
que ce principe est constitutif de
l'université républicaine c'est à dire
que la société française doit à sa
jeunesse
un accès à partir du moment où le niveau
nécessaire à l'éducation à
l'enseignement supérieur et donc on est
dans une dans une conception de
l'université qui n'est pas celle qu'on
nous impose depuis une bonne vingtaine
d'années maintenant puisque le en fait
on a des réformes successives qui qui
interviennent sur l'université depuis
assez longtemps un qui remonte à au
processus de bologne en 99 2000 qui font
rentrer en fait l'université dans ce
qu'on a appelé l'économie de la
connaissance
c'est à dire une conception où le savoir
universitaire le savoir académique est
considéré comme du capital humain 1
qu'il faut acquérir pour favoriser son
insertion professionnelle et augmenter
son employabilité
ça c'est une conception qui s'est imposé
depuis une vingtaine d'années et qui est
qui est aussi très très présente dans
l'esprit de la réforme par coups reçus
puisqu'on a l'idée avec conjuguée avec
la réforme du du baccalauréat en fait
toutes ont tous fait système on a l'idée
qu'il faut anticiper de plus en plus tôt
dès l'entrée en seconde maintenant ses
choix d'orientation dans le supérieur en
fonction des perspectives d'insertion
professionnelle donc c'est tout une
concept en fait à travers cette
plateforme on n'a pas une réforme qui
est purement technique
on pourrait on pourrait penser que c'est
purement technique en fait c'est en fait
c'est profondément idéologique le
gouvernement la base présente ça aussi
pour éviter les problèmes de l'été
dernier au bout du soulier se sont
retrouvés sans formation tout le monde
était visiblement d'accord pour dire il
faut changer les choses est ce que vous
pensez aussi que les choses devaient
changer le statu quo est absolument
indéfendable la situer sur l'université
est révoltante mais depuis très très
longtemps pourquoi parce que le système
d'enseignement supérieur à la française
fonctionne de façon du alizés c'est à
dire que vous avez l'université dont les
droits d'inscription sont pour l'instant
assez faible qui
es tu l'accès est universel enfin un
appartement vous êtes bacheliers et puis
vous avez les classes préparatoires et
les grandes écoles dans lesquelles on
sait depuis très longtemps que en
fonction de si vous êtes enfant de cadre
aux enfants d'ouvriers les chances sont
pas du tout les mêmes d'accéder à ces
formations qui sont qui sont sélectives
et que la réforme ça ça change
absolument pas avec parcours ses pains
on reste avec dante et antiques parcours
su on tend vers ceux vers ce modèle ce
modèle là privé valorisation alors on
n'est pas encore dans un modèle privé
mais c'est que c'est une marche vers ce
système là je pense que la réforme pour
ça qu'elle a un côté un côté absurde
qu'on a dénoncé c'est qu'elle va nous
surchargés de travail là en fait
puisqu'on va se retrouver là à partir de
maintenant
théoriquement nous ont reçus de le faire
mais voilà à gérer des voeux qui ne sont
pas rares chizé en amont une dizaine de
voeux il ya dix jeux lors alors avec des
subtilités parce que si vous allez en
médecine vous pouvez faire des jeux
multi core et d'une complexité
redoutable sur le plan technique mais en
tout cas il va falloir gérer ses voeux
ils sont pas hiérarchiser en amont donc
ça veut dire que pendant tout l'été
jusqu'à jusqu'à la rentrée universitaire
il va falloir qu'on gère des flux
d'étudiants qui vont faire qui vont se
désister parce qu'ils auront d'ailleurs
et dont concret une somme de travail
monumental pour les personnels
administratifs les personnels
enseignants pointent à la fin arriver à
une situation où en fait on va se
retrouver que des effectifs qui vous qui
seront qui seront semblables à ce qu'on
avait cette année c'est à dire ça va
être un travail totalement absurde
frédéric vidal dit que contrairement à
l'an passé la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur
contrairement à l'an passé personne ne
sera laissé sur le carreau tout le monde
aura une formation et que même si alors
le terme sélection une nouvelle fois
n'est pas accepté par le gouvernement
mais que tout le monde aura forcément un
choix qu'il souhaitait ou en tout cas
qui on lui proposera un choix qui
correspond à ses attentes on croyait pas
à cet argument là la question c'est pas
c'est pas si tout le monde aura une
place ses séquelles place c'est à dire
que pour gérer ces flux en fait
beaucoup d'étudiants vont être en
attente pendant pendant pendant tout
l'été les premières réponses d'ailleurs
en rappel vont tomber d'ici le 22 mai
toutefois dire déjà peut-être aux
bacheliers aux futurs bacheliers et ils
nous regardent qu'ils ont une semaine
pour répondre donc faut rester oisif
d'ailleurs nous est tout à fait à partir
de fin juin ses vingt-quatre heures
après 24 heures donc on ne part pas en
vacances mais j'espère que ce sera quand
même possible mais donc donc
effectivement le discours de la ministre
c'est tout le monde aura une place là
que la question c'est quelle place
puisque les universités sont confrontés
à une situation financière qui fait
qu'elles n'embauchent plus de personnel
enseignant et que ce personnel
enseignant est en baisse pour la
première fois depuis une trentaine
d'années depuis depuis qu'on a créé les
corps d'enseignants universitaires et
que donc mécaniquement on a des filières
par exemple janssen et en adresse où on
a des td qui menace d'une cinquantaine
d'inscrits
donc on va se retrouver avec des
déformations dans lesquels on va
concentrer les étudiants car on était en
attente pendant tout l'été ont pourtant
des conditions d'enseignement qui sont
pas acceptables pour vous faut plus
d'embaucher plus de policiers à gauche
et des enseignants bien bien bien bien
il faut créer des ministres c'est un
premier un milliard d'euros sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat sur l'instant
elle n'est pas suffisant c'est des
miettes que jetair le crédit impôt
recherche ces 6 milliards d'euros voilà
donc moi je propose qu'on prenne une
partie du crédit impôt recherche qui
nous permet pas d'embaucher des
chercheurs dans les entreprises pour
financer vraiment l'université un mot
sur sur sur les blocages qui ont lieu en
ce moment où une certaine dans certaines
facs
est ce que vous vous soutenez ce mode
d'organisation qui ne touchent pas pour
l'instant levé est ce qu par exemple
mais qui qui bloque on va dire
pour pour beaucoup est-ce que vous pour
vous c'est la bonne méthode de bloquer
les facultés ouais je remarque que la
ministre ça fait six mois qu'elle
explique que la plateforme n'est pas un
instrument de sélection tout le monde
est en train de comprendre que c'est
quand même bien le but inavoué delà de
la réforme elle campe sur ses positions
donc je
je constate que le blocage est la seule
alternative possible pour les pour les
étudiants pour se faire entendre c'est
pour ça que vous m'invitez ça qu'on en
parle parce que les universités sont
bloquées
donc je considère que c'est un moyen
légitime pour pour faire émerger ce
débat qui me paraît légitime
en tout cas la polémique enfle depuis
quelques jours à propos d' intervention
policière dans certaines universités à
la sorbonne jeudi soir ou en début de
semaine à nanterre écoutez à ce propos
frédéric vidal elle était interrogée sur
ce sujet précisément au sénat c'était
mardi
il est très important de ne pas mélanger
deux choses ce qui se passe
effectivement dans certaines universités
avec des étudiants qui débattent qui
sont à l'assemblée générale qui parfois
conteste et c'est leur droit
et puis la violence qui est organisé par
de petits groupes qui n'ont qu'une
volonté s'est trouvé une tribune au sein
des universités et j ai je tiens à vous
le dire
les universités sont des lieux de
liberté des lieux de débat et ce ne sont
pas des lieux que l'on peut récupérer
politiquement une réflexion peut-être ça
ressemble un peu ce qui se passe dans
l'université en ce moment à allah aux
protestations contre la réforme du code
du travail finalement on oublier le fond
et on voyait que les casseurs que les
que la minorité est ce que vous n'avez
pas peur que le mouvement qui est
peut-être le vôtre qui est qui est sain
qui est qui et pacifiste soit finalement
oublié par ces quelques personnes qui
sont très politisés très très violente
c'est évidemment le risque mais la
ministre joue le pourrissement très
clairement puisqu'elle elle le donne
l'ordre
aux présidents d'université de faire
intervenir les forces de l'ordre sur les
campus alors que c'est un principe qui
depuis l'université des mots médiévale
depuis depuis le xiième siècle laisse en
sécurité d'accord d'accord
le principe de de l'université c'est que
c'est que c'est une cette année soit
indépendant du pouvoir politique et dans
lequel les forces de l'ordre non non non
rien à faire en principe depuis depuis
depuis très très longtemps donc l ati ce
feu là vous vous disiez en tout cas
c'est donc moi je remarque je remarque
que je ya eu des incidents très graves
dans la l'université de montpellier ya
plus de trois semaines ou d'être
plusieurs enquêtes sont en cours on n'a
pas à aller les résultats mais la
ministre a toujours pris aucune sanction
sérieuse à l'égard d'enseignants qui ont
participé ou en tout cas qui ont
encouragé
quand même du tabassage d'étudiants dans
l'université quand même hélas
je constate que rien
c'est pour ça que je parle de
pourrissement c'est que là les mesures
de sanctions elles n'ont pas été prises
pour l'instant et on suivra évidemment
de près les évolutions et l'avenir de
cette réforme voir aussi si le mouvement
prend à l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci matthieu
hély d'être venu sur le plateau de tv 78
et d'avoir répondu à toutes nos
questions vous êtes je le rappelle
enseignants chercheurs à lui vécu
codirecteur du parcours politique
sociale territoriale merci à vous et bon
week-end on passe désormais à
l'actualité de la semaine
la nouvelle est tombée par surprise
lundi les maires des villes de maurepas
et de coignard ont annoncé leur
intention de fusionner pour créer une
commune nouvelle celle ci pourrait avoir
voir le jour excusez moi le 1er janvier
prochain ce rassemblement permettrait
notamment de mutualiser les moyens des
collectivités et de faire face à la
baisse des dotations de l'état c'est
l'argument en tout cas affiché par les
deux maires les détails avec aurélie
rose et marion ptac on se remet ensemble
une volonté commune pour un nouvel
ensemble territorial coignières et
maurepas partagent déjà un même code
postal de nombreux projets
intercommunaux archives déchetterie
police municipale un centre aquatique et
bientôt une nouvelle identité
il faut qu'on aille justement dans cette
formidable aventure qui est historique
pour nos habitants et audacieuse en
termes de qualité de service public du
service public on va proposer à nos
habitants c'est à dire de toujours faire
mieux avec nos moyens
une décision partie motivée par la
baisse des dotations de l'état ne
souhaitant pas augmenter les impôts les
maires de coignières et maurepas ont
décidé de s'unir
un mariage qui devrait intervenir le 1er
janvier 2019
depuis 2010 la loi permet en effet aux
communes de regrouper leurs
administrations respectives
actuellement en france il existe cinq
cent cinquante sept communes nouvelles
un nouveau mode de fonctionnement qui
seraient exposés à la population dans
les prochaines semaines il y aura besoin
d'information d'écouté de compréhension
aussi de la population de nos
administrés et donc c'est une phase
d'ici à la fin de l'année et je dirais
même à l'automne d'ici à l'automne c'est
une phase très très importante
on ne fait pas pour nous on le fait pour
les habitants pour garantir une qualité
de service public qui est tant attendu
par nos populations
un projet d'avenir qui donnera lieu à de
nombreux changements un seul maire mais
aussi un nouveau nom pour cette commune
nouvelle
nous aurons besoin d'une votation besoin
de l'avis de la population et il faudra
conserver également l'esprit mort passe
bien mais aussi l'esprit coignières dans
le dos dans le dans le nom de cette
nouvelle commune et ce sera déterminée
d'ici
d'ici quelques mois rue dès cette
semaine les habitants de maurepas et
coignières recevront une lettre
explicative sur cette ambition connu
et cette annonce a suscité de nombreuses
réactions depuis lundi notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux de tv soixante dix huit
facebook et twitter mercredi grégory
gary astier et jean-pierre sevestre les
maires respectivement de maurepas et
coignard étaient les invités du journal
mercredi c'était donc ils ont pu
notamment regarder ces quelques
réactions recueillies d'habitants par la
rédaction de tv 78 ça peut être un plus
maintenant après je sais pas c'est une
bonne chose voilà parce que on n'a pas
vraiment tout ici mais à maurepas ya
beaucoup de choses donc c'est à
proximité pour nous il peut obliger
aussi actuellement de travailler
ensemble pour pouvoir encore plus de
réactivité
bah c'est une bonne chose ça pour ça
permet un rapace à rapprocher les les
habitants les uns avec les autres
les gens qui habitent à cogner arrive
enfin l'archos ici lambert au commerce
en plus de nous étendre un petit peu sur
le secteur et moi je pense que c'est
bien que les villes sont grandes mieux
mieux ses soeurs à gérer plus on aura de
potentiel pour pour investir et pour
avoir une grande ville c'est bien ça
évite les frais je pense donc on divise
les frais par deux m'aurait pas cogner
ça je vais que ça soit il a un coût et
m'aurait pas mais moi je viens tout pas
l'utilité surtout que c'est un peu plus
connu que et lincou à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines faudra-t-il
bientôt parler de communauté urbaine et
non plus deux communautés
d'agglomération
la question est désormais posée a même
été débattu mercredi soir en conseil
communautaire
à l'occasion du vote du budget un
changement de statut qui permettrait de
dégager une nouvelle manne financière
alors que la pression fiscale s'accroît
sur l'agglomération les détails avec ce
reportage
c'est un trésor de 13 millions d'euros
que doit trouver la gloire à sion de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'avantagé fiscal dont bénéficie la
collectivité pour sa participation au
système de péréquation sera remise en
cause dès l'an prochain pour trouver de
l'argent sans augmenter les impôts ou
réduire les services la majorité
réfléchit donc à évoluer et pourrait
rejoindre le club très fermé des
communautés urbaines
ça nous donnerait une bouffée d'air de
l'ordre de 8 à 9 millions d'euros par an
pour pouvoir se poser et prendre le
temps peut-être pour faire d'autres
réformes sur le long terme pour changer
de statut saint-quentin-en-yvelines
devra nouveau s'élargir pour atteindre
le seuil de 250 mille habitants une
option que l'opposition de gauche ne
rejette pas même si pour elle un large
débat territoriale doit être rapidement
mise en place
la base c'est une discussion d'abord
entre nous par rapport aux différentes
compétences qu'on souhaite et aux
différentes une coopération qu'on
souhaite entre nos communes et après on
verra
vers qui on se tourne cette discussion
s'est inscrit dans le vote plus large du
budget 550 millions d'euros approuvée
par les élus avec 46 voix pour et 25
abstentions un budget qualifié de
transition et d'attentes par la majorité
les délibérations pour le transfert de
compétences patine depuis plusieurs mois
on est une seule intercours bien avant
tours on est douze nerfs et avant de
penser peut-être à l'intercommunalité
chaque maire défend un peu sa propre
ville on n'a pas trouvé encore le rythme
qu'il faut et c'est vrai que sans ce
rythme là on a du mal à se projeter dans
l'avenir
les élus ont également voté le maintien
des impôts locaux à leur taux actuel
le prochain conseil d'agglomération est
prévue le 29 mai prochain l'évolution de
l'intercommunalité devrait une nouvelle
fois rythmé les débats en politique les
militants yvelinois des républicains ne
choisirons qu'en octobre prochain leur
nouveau président pour remplacer david
douillet mais la campagne a déjà bel et
bien débuté avec deux candidats
officiellement en lice face à pierre
bédier le président du département
alexandra dublanche conseiller régional
de 35 ans va faire équipe avec un autre
élu régional le trappistes othmana
through pour je cite donner une nouvelle
image du parti le duo peut compter
notamment sur le soutien du maire de
vélizy villacoublay pascal thévenot
de son côté pierre bédier doit faire
face du coup à quelques remous après l
annonce de sa candidature en mars
dernier mardi le président du
département organisé une réunion
publique pour évoquer l'avenir de la
droite et des républicains des
républicains il en a profité aussi pour
revenir sur son engagement pour la
fédération locale
écoutez j'ai envie de partager avec ses
militants bonne expérience parce que
c'est ça que je peux apporter l'énergie
des convictions qui est toujours là et
puis l'expérience et pour faire émerger
une nouvelle génération qui a encore à
apprendre cette nouvelle génération elle
a connu la défaite
l âme
connu quelques fois personnellement et
donc bon ils ont je pense besoin de ce
mixte entre eux de l'expérience encore
avec de l'énergie
et puis de l'énergie sans doute plus
forte mais avec encore une expérience à
guérir c'est ce mix qu'on essaye de
mettre en oeuvre enfin à droite
également le mouvement sens commun né au
moment de la manif pour tous sont en
2013 a désormais une nouvelle présidente
il s'agit de laurence trochut 44 ans
conseillère départementale du canton de
montigny le bretonneux
elle succède à madeleine de gc de gc le
mouvement compte dans les yvelines une
trentaine d'élus un robot chirurgical
pour assister les médecins lors des
opérations c'est la nouvelle acquisition
de l'hôpital privé les franciscaines à
versailles il en existe 120 de ce type
en france un appareil qui permet de
réduire la période d'hospitalisation des
patients et un rétablissement aussi plus
rapide
reportage de camille lambert attention
certaines images peuvent choquer la
sensibilité
il a des allures de cockpit ce robot
chirurgical nouvelle génération a
rejoint la clinique privée des
franciscaines à versailles d'avancé ici
c'est son nom permet d'offrir de
meilleures conditions d'hospitalisation
pour les patients mais aussi pour les
chirurgiens pour le docteur g ne vois
c'est une première beaucoup moins
fatigués au lieu de rester deux à trois
heures debout en tenant des instruments
donc les épaules un peu surélevé
là on est assis à la console du robot et
puis on a voilà on est moins crispés sur
les pinces
on a une liberté de mouvement qui est
sans équivalent en coelioscopie et une
vision en trois dimensions qui fatiguent
beaucoup moins cette patiente souffrait
d'une descente d'organes avec ses bras
et ses pinces articuler le robot a
permis d'accrocher plus facilement des
bandelettes pour stopper la maladie à
l'origine utilisés dans la chirurgie
urologique
ce robot peut aussi être utile en
gynécologie le docteur apfelbaum
l'utilisent chaque semaine depuis le
début de l'année c'est un vrai plus pour
le patient en terme de ce qu'on appelle
la réhabilitation précoce j'ai vraiment
l'impression que les patientes sont
beaucoup plus confortable
j'ai une courbe d'apprentissage parce
que c'est vraiment une technique
nouvelle qui s'est tout à fait bien
déroulée et qui me permette de
maintenant faite d'accéder à des cas
difficiles
j'ai vraiment l'impression que le geste
est plus simple dans les cas difficiles
seul inconvénient à prendre cette
nouvelle technique et le coût pour les
hôpitaux
le premier robot arrivé il ya sept ans à
la clinique a été remplacé par ce modèle
à 2 millions d'euros
il en existe seulement 120 dans toute la
france c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo
retour de l'actualité en direct lundi à
18h sur l'antenne de tv 78 d'ici là
restez connectés et informés grâce à
notre site internet et nos réseaux
sociaux et aussi l'application tv 78 bon
week-end à tous à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]